I'm not risking knocking it into a ocean
if you do not choose one both of them
will hey mom yeah okay I need help so
I've been seeing a lot of these don't
push the wrong mystery box into the
water videos that is in one of these
boxes and he has no idea what you guys
chose but I put out a poll on Instagram
and you guys decided which box I should
push it to the water I thought it'd be
interesting if we raised the stakes
so I decided how to use a parent rather
than put Eric in a box I decided I would
put one of Eric's most prized
possessions in the box I'm going to
enlist the help of a day we are both
going to go out on a boat with these two
boxes one has Eric's boosted board the
other one is just filled with weights
Eric will have to allow his Instagram
followers to choose which box we knock
into I know I might seem like just a
mean-spirited bull but Eric pranks us
all the time good morning guys I'm
wearing a tank top in the office right
now because I'm going on a boat today
they want me to help shoot I don't know
what they want for me but I get it on a
boat so I'm gonna go let's go we're
gonna follow baby
you brought me here to be the GoPro guy
and why it's a dua both of you guys tell
me right now
you guys just seem like creepy porn
directors right now what are we gonna do
on this boat what's the video what are
you guys gonna do to me I get it I
already know it's a prank have you ever
seen that show that's the that show
Dexter huh please no harder than to get
murdered
tell me just set
what's in the box right okay
so I thought it would be interesting to
do a video with you and your Instagram
followers where you take photos of these
mystery boxes and you allow them to pick
which Boxey they put in the wall that's
it that's the odd this whole setup was
for a mystery box video throwing
something into the water yeah let's do
it and now I gotta plug my in stuff you
get to put your amazing alright what's
up guys I'm in the middle I don't know
we're in the water on a boat and two
producers at BuzzFeed want you guys to
decide which box to push in box a or box
B which one I have nothing else that's
it water is in the boxes mystery box
yeah in one of these boxes it's just
random yeah yeah nothing nothing
important in a different box is your
boosted board
so we took your boosted board and put it
in one announce table dude no I'm not
you know dude I got a Brewster board for
$1,300 I'm not risking knocking it into
a ocean this is the bay okay I'm not
knocking in my boosted board you're
telling me one of these boxes has my
booster board one of these box when did
you get my Brewster board out of that
this morning all right I'm not gonna
I'll get hold it I'm gonna knock either
one of these in these are the rules
ready we faked it I'll do it if we fake
it like you hold on huh let me give you
the rules I'm gonna allow you to push in
the the mystery box that your followers
choose they don't know if you do not
choose one both of them will that's so
mean bro I drove two hours for you to
think the one thing I care about like
I'm and throw in the ocean the bed okay
no no it these videos yeah get five to
ten million views each and then they
follow the users account those are
Instagram followers that you could get
but you won't get them if we don't make
this video this is the most weird
situation I've ever been should I should
I make a viral video and potentially
lose a $1,300 board disagree with me if
this is wrong okay followers equals
money
what if you get more followers and this
board is worth and you're just throwing
that away I should call my manager real
quick that's gonna call his mom hey mom
okay I need help they want me to do a
mystery box video one of the boxes has
my booster board in it and the other has
a bunch of chunk I don't know which is
which and I have to pick I have to push
one into the water like let's say I get
like 20,000 followers from that video is
it worth it
you idiot
fine okay I'm gonna dull I'll make a
choice thank you mom let's do it yeah
yeah
yeah whatever it's gonna do well my
theory is that if I push it in I don't
think you guys will let me push in the
board like I think if they pick the
board you guys don't let it happen I'm
shaking you see my finger
52% said be
there's no audience no news for you
okay so what went wrong with it oh we
don't know
I can't even go down please
goddang stop recording and help me get
my board I'm not going until we get my
board are you guys leaving me in the
water guys right okay no stop
what
okay so I want to address a few of the
things that you might be thinking one we
didn't litter I went back and I
retrieved the box too
the reason we never see any of Eric's
GoPro footage is because Eric dropped it
in the bay and it sank so maybe we did
litter for not on purpose and three
wouldn't let Eric knock his boosted
board into the water
in fact his boosted board never left the
office
[Music]
I told you you weren't gonna do
are there any hard feelings about this
now honestly like as weird as it sounds
I mean like you guys like really it was
really neat but I feel like that makes
us like really good friends yeah we're
on another level of friendship because
like my friends are always really mean
to me I don't think your friendship is
know it it is cuz I'm gonna prank you
guys back
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part